this episode is brought to you by tonal
that's t-o-n-a-l
tonal is the world's most intelligent
home gym and personal trainer
that's the tagline from their website
folks so it gives you the one sentence
summary
by eliminating traditional metal weights
tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen
tv it mounts right on your wall with no
floor space required
i've had one for a few months now after
a number of close friends
recommended tonal to me and it allows me
to do things that i would normally need
a huge
gym for like cable chop and lift or
rotational exercises and it allows me to
do other things
that are nearly impossible otherwise
like eccentric loading which i'll talk
about again later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights
and ai learning together with the best
experts in resistance training so you
can get stronger
faster one of my friends who used to be
a competitive skier
very high level competitive skier has
doubled his strength in many exercises
over a period of months
so what are these adaptive digital
weights tonal's patented
digital weight system makes thousands of
calculations a second to deliver you a
smooth
weightlifting experience using their
advanced electronic motor technology
and a lot of the buttons are built right
into the handles themselves
into the grips so you don't need to move
around and
it is extremely easy to use tonal lets
you adjust the weight in one pound
increments and you can do it on the fly
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down with just the touch
of a button
tonal also has built-in dynamic weight
modes like
chains eccentric and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains and bands
the eccentrics which i mentioned means
that you can
set a mode that allows you to say just
as an example
bicep curl 15 pounds up and then lower
automatically 20 25 pounds down
and it is incredible how much you can
get done
in just a handful of minutes when you
use this type of technology
so check it out tri-tonal t-o-n-a-l the
world's smartest home gym for 30 days in
your home and if you don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.com
t-o-n-a-l dot com and for a limited time
get 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code
tim21 like i'm ready for
my first drink at checkout that's
www.tonaltonal.com
promo code tim21 tim21
tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely all form furniture
i've got
two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional
couch and i'll come back to that you can
pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using what i
am sharing with you guys and if getting
a sofa without trying it in store sounds
risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined
and i'm very very happy so to find your
perfect sofa check out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m-com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout at this altitude i can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to
interview world-class performers from
all different disciplines all different
walks of life my guest today is
elizabeth
lesser she is a best-selling author and
the co-founder of
omega institute the renowned conference
and retreat center located in rhinebeck
new york i have a lot to say about omega
and we'll visit that in the early
portions of this conversation
elizabeth's first book the seeker's
guide chronicles her years at omega and
distills lessons learned into a potent
guide for growth and healing
her new york times best-selling book
broken open subtitled how difficult
times can help us grow
has sold almost 500 000 copies and has
been translated into 20 languages
her third book marrow chronicles the
journey elizabeth and her younger sister
went through when elizabeth was the
donor for her sister's bone marrow
transplant and her newest book cassandra
speaks
when women are the storytellers the
human story changes
reveals how humanity has outgrown its
origin tales and
hero myths we'll also find out if it's
cassandra or cassandra
i never quite know elizabeth has given
two popular ted talks and is one of
oprah winfrey's super soul 100 a
collection of
100 leaders who are using their voices
and talent to elevate humanity
she co-founded omega institute in 1977 a
time when a variety of fresh ideas were
sprouting up in american culture
since then the institute has been at the
forefront of holistic education offering
workshops
and conferences in integrative medicine
meditation and yoga
cross-cultural arts and creativity
ecumenical spirituality and social
change each year close to 30 000 people
participate in omega's programs on its
campus
and more than a million people visit its
website for online learning
you can find her online at elizabeth
lesser that's l-e-s-s-e-r
org on facebook eliz lesser instagram
liz lesser and on twitter at elizabeth
lesser elizabeth welcome to the show
hey thank you tim thank you for having
me i'm thrilled because
not only have i taken trapeze classes
at omega but i have to tell you a story
just to kick this off i recall the first
time i visited
omega in upstate new york it was to take
a class that you were offering
with jersey and angela gregoric who are
two incredible olympic weightlifters
originally from poland
now uh jersey is certainly in his 60s
and they're just
incredible human beings the epitome of
fitness
and while i was there i took my first
yoga class in one of your beautiful
beautiful structures
and i'm in the middle of taking this
class there are huge windows
behind the instructor and i spot a
squirrel
and i start to think to myself am i on
drugs right now
because that is the strangest looking
most gigantic squirrel i've ever seen in
my entire life
and you can imagine what that was it was
one of your
of your groundhogs they're everywhere
these huge groundhogs
and it's just a beautiful location a
beautiful center and you offer
incredible programming so i wanted to
share that you would think that from my
years of being
involved in omega and our curriculum
that i'd have
like that i'd be a true believer in
everything but i'm not
i like have a massive [ __ ] detector
but
those animals at omega from 40 plus
years of us being on that campus they
are
tame sort of in the way you would
imagine
that animals around humans who are
trying to be their most conscious selves
would not be as afraid you know you hear
that sort of theory
but it's really been proven like the fox
will just walk across and
sit there and watch people and those
woodchucks
are absolutely tame and they're the bay
and bane of our gardener
they're huge i i had never spent time
around woodchucks
aka groundhogs and they're adorable and
you see people taking photo ops with
them and so on so it was quite the
experience and i was i was thrilled to
get edumacated on groundhogs but let's
let's back up and go back in time and i
am going to butcher this pronunciation
but could you please tell us
who is pure vilayat
inayat khan and i suppose first you
should probably say that name
correctly you're almost there it's pier
goliath inaudible
pier is the name for teacher
in arabic islam and
pirvalaya khan was
he died a decade ago a sufi
teacher sufism being the mystical
dimension of islam
and when i was in
college in new york city it was that
time in american history where like
eastern gurus were like watching up on
the shores of america
and i was very much
you know i was at columbia so it was the
1970s
a lot of uh social action a lot of
anti-war
civil rights feminism i was very
involved in that
but the more it got violent and
just sort of to the far edge of my
revolutionary self
the more i realized this is not working
for me
and i became very interested in eastern
spirituality
and christian mysticism and all kinds of
things
and um one day i was walking across the
columbia campus and i heard this
singing coming from one of the buildings
and it was
a bunch of young people doing a circle
dance holding hands and chanting
the different names of god in all these
different religious traditions and i
thought
wow this is what i want i want this i
want to get me
this and i started hanging out with this
group of people whose teacher
was pier velayet anayat khan i had never
heard of him i knew nothing about sufism
i came from a very intellectual
anti-religion atheistic
family or like holy text was the new
yorker magazine
and anyone who you know was like an
equation if you believed in god or if
you had any spiritual longing in you
that meant you were not smart
or you were not valid but i was just
like born a seeker
i was like always like going to mass
with my catholic next door neighbor i
just wanted
some answers to this insane situation we
all found ourselves in
so i discovered my first spiritual
teacher
pierre velayet khan and i got a deep
education in the sufi tradition
which you know islam if we think it's
kind of foreign now
no one knew about it and here was this
erudite scholarly man who was
half southern indian muslim
southern indian and half american his
mother was actually a relative of the
founder of christian
science and had met this holy traveling
guru
pierre velaite's father in that time in
america in the 1910s
twenties when there was a great
awakening happening
pierre velaya was uh
lived in paris grew up in paris under
the tutelage of his
sufi muslim father and his free
free-thinking american mother
he fought in world war ii he came to
america at this time when all these
hippies
were interested in spirituality but
he was very interested in excellence
in discipline in scholarship
and he was interested in all the world
religions
and holism and health he's like a real
polymath
a super polymath and he attracted around
him
young people who were somewhat similar
kind of type a spiritual seekers
and that is my root tradition and it was
he who had the idea to start a holistic
learning center and he put
myself and my ex-husband in charge of it
and that's what became
omega institute what an answer
you're good at this oh i have been long
looking forward to this
conversation and you have proved that
excitement to be well founded
that that's the uh cliff notes the cliff
notes the cliffhangers well there are a
bunch of footnotes
in that cliff note that i want to click
on first just a confession it's not
really a confession it's more of
a disclosure because confession sort of
implies something scandalous
i'm looking around me right now and i
have
a collection of poems which is titled
the gift which is a collection of poetry
translated of course
of hafez who is my favorite poet
also known as a sufi
and often considered considered
certainly by
many to be the sort of pinnacle
of certain types of literature in the
the persian speaking world
and that led me to
a number of books including tales of the
dervishes
by and i'm going to mispronounce this
also
and if you had told tim of
not even 30 years ago 20 years ago 15
years ago that i would be reading these
things associated
with even tangentially any monotheistic
religion i would have laughed that would
have been scoffed
but it's the mysticism it's this direct
experience that is so interesting to me
and i'm i'm wondering what it was
in you if you could expand that you were
seeking
if you grew up in this family where the
scripture was the new yorker
and to have an element
or perhaps a seeking of faith was viewed
as
a rejection of rationality i'm these are
my words not yours but i
i certainly have been myself a militant
atheist
no longer would consider myself such
what is it that you were looking for
and why was it that
pier velayet am i getting that right
here
khan was the first to really scratch the
itch properly
well he scratched it and so did several
other people
simultaneously at the same time because
as i said it was a time in history where
like
yoga and mindfulness and buddhism and
tibetan teachers and
people from all over the east were
arriving here
you know some sort of karmic need in
western
culture attracted this wave
of eastern philosophy and
all of these young people who had been
their doors of perception
had been opened either through
psychedelics
or just this distaste for 1950s
american rigidity the generational
culture change i had
an enormous longing in me sufi's always
used the word
longing that that god is longing for you
and you are longing for god god being
not a being
but as you said a mystical connection
to the universe words fail
here words really fail when you start
getting into the realm of the numinous
and
mysticism but i was always
aware that what i saw
and what was going on that could not be
everything the answer to what was
happening in nature
in energy i just as a little kid i was
just like a nerdy mystic kid
i was always like what is going
on here and why won't anyone tell me
where did i come from where do i go
without when i die
and what happens in between those
bookends is there a good way to live
is there a way to live with more
connectivity to other people
communication i was just con massively
confused and massively curious
so when i had a chance to delve
into these different disciplines another
first teacher for me
was cho gyam rinpoche
who was a tibetan master
who came to this country and was
absolutely
perfectly geared for america he was
young
he had escaped tibet through a very
courageous
crossing of the himalayas with many
thousands of his people
the dalai lama decided he was going to
be one of the young
tibetan teachers who takes tibetan
culture
to the west he studied at oxford he came
to america
he started naropa that institute in
boulder colorado
and he wrote what i consider to be my
favorite spiritual book which is
shambhala
the sacred path of the warrior so i
learned
buddhist meditation from him but what i
learned from purevaliate khan and why
sufism
became my root path was
he often talked about the emotion of
illumination
that it wasn't just transcendence
into a realm where there was no human
emotion
there was actually a way to bring your
heart and your feelings
and your awe and your ecstasy along with
you
on the path you didn't have to become
sort of a dried out buddhist kind of
you know emptiness sort of an
enlightened
desiccated void yeah a seeker of
emptiness
he was a seeker of fullness and life
and and he often talked about the
emotion
of illumination and as a young
kind of woman who was
just didn't want to let go of my
femaleness that really appealed to me
that i could be an emotional creature
and a spiritual seeker
so if we go back to those very early
chapters
in the formation the creation of
the omega institute do you use the the
omega institute or do you generally say
omega institute and leave out the
god i love you for asking that it's one
of my pet peeves i always leave
out the v but most of the people who
work at omega now put in the v
and i'm just the titular head so i can't
say anymore
i leave off the v
okay i'll do my best i'll do my best i
have a very close friend
matt mullenweg who was one of the lead
developers or the lead developer of
wordpress the platform upon which a lot
of
the 30 plus percent of the internet is
now based and
almost no one capitalizes the p in
wordpress and it drives him
crazy similar uh
so if we look at those early very early
formative let's just call it the first
formative chapter
of omega institute what did the first
draft
look like what did the prototype
look like for omega institute
and how did you decide on what to
include versus
exclude well we had been living
communally pierre velayet khan
i first spent my first couple of years
in his presence as one of his students
in california
and then he decided he wanted to start a
commune
he wanted his students to not only live
together but also to test spiritual
principles in the real world create our
own businesses create our own
economic system families how are we
going to raise our kids it was like a
petri dish for
how would you walk the talk and so
we ended up through very strange
circumstances
purchasing an old shaker village
on the north side of a mountain in the
berkshire mountains
back on the east coast on the new york
side of the berkshires
in a town called new lebanon new york
and this was the first settlement
of the shakers which was a
community of christian seekers who were
also living their practice
being the change and
they built these amazing structures
in different parts of mostly the
northeast but also
ohio and we ended up buying one
how we did it is a fascinating story but
you may not have time for that you know
the benefit of long form is we've got
nothing but time so
okay so i would love to hear more about
these very strange circumstances
i'm guessing you didn't go to
shakervillage.com and buy what was for
sale that's my guess
well first of all it was 1975
and we were living in marin county
and we were living the kind of you know
post summer of love spiritual seekers
california dream and then suddenly
pierre vlad had this idea we need to go
back to the land
we need to become self-sufficient and we
need to see
if these things were talking about
mindfulness and
love if they really work so we're going
to go do an experiment in living and and
this was
like 300 of us and so
one of the students in the bay area
in our group was the wife of a man named
wavy gravy
wavy gravy was the master of ceremonies
at the woodstock festival and really
like an
icon of hippie dumb and his
wife was from the east coast and her
parents
owned this summer camp in an old shaker
village
and that is how we came to buy this huge
tract of land and these
amazing huge enormous buildings
uh for dirt cheap because we had no
money
and then everyone picked up and moved
across the country
and settled in these falling down
buildings and we proceeded to create
a community of businesses and school
and prayer and spiritual practice
and it was out of that that omega
institute
emerged because pirifolia realized not
everyone in fact
almost no one was going to want to live
communally the way we were
and sure enough very soon afterwards
none of us wanted to live that way
either
so he put myself and my ex
husband who is a medical doctor dr
stefan rekshoffen in charge of this idea
he had
create a learning institute of holism
he was a great aficionado
of the libraries of alexandria
he loved the history of that time that
era
where it was the first example of the
three abrahamic religions coming
together and
influencing each other mathematics early
science
and he wanted us to recreate the ancient
schools of alexandria
a good deal of time we had no idea what
he was speaking about
because he was just so highly educated
and erudite and brilliant but because
stefan was a doctor and i was a
i had gotten my college degree in
education and i
and i was a curious seeker myself
he put us in charge and of course the
first
year we xeroxed a few pieces of paper
and invited a few teachers
and rented a private
prep school in upstate new york and
maybe a hundred people
came some of our first teachers were
people who now
are household names but then they had no
platform
deepak chopra he was a uh he had just
left harvard and was just starting his
medical practice
elizabeth kubler-ross death and dying
expert
no one wanted to talk about death and
dying then
african dance teachers all sorts of
different
genres of learning that there was
nowhere for them to teach
so after that first year we we grew very
quickly we would grow in these
leaps that we could barely keep up with
it was like omega was this monster that
we were running after
and for the first three years we did
not have our own home we rented
different spaces
the last place we rented was bennington
college
in vermont and we had to use their
food service which was like sloppy joes
and
potato chips and then just to appease us
they would like
have a bucket of raw tofu blocks at the
end of the line
kind of thing grab a handful
nobody knew what we were trying to do
you know
food as medicine that was very new
eastern spirituality that was anathema
to
america yoga mindfulness alternative
health
this was all far out on the fringes of
american culture
eventually we realized we needed our own
home
and without any real money
or know-how we bought this old yiddish
kids camp in the hudson valley that was
had been
uninhabited for 10 years
all the pipes were burst the electrical
wires were down
we had like three months between buying
it and opening
fortunately our early students didn't
care now people expect much more
upgraded housing at that point people
were like
sleeping in rooms with bats flying
around
so anyway the early prototype
was both high falutin based on pier
velite's
intellectual prowess and just
young scrappy people having to
run a business you know it's a business
and
we needed to make this thing work
financially so that we could hire people
we didn't pay ourselves for like the
first nine or ten years
it was definitely a labor of passion
wow and we're gonna make it past like
chapter one in your life
of many uh because i'm gonna have so
many questions but
i to pause for just a second because you
said something
that i think is worth exploring and that
is after a while we didn't want to live
communally either so
let me just bookmark that and
i think it's worth saying or i believe
that those who don't study history are
condemned to repeat it
and there are many communities now uh
many movements one might even say now
that rhyme with the movements and
excitement different breeds of
excitement of
the the 60s and 70s this includes the
so-called psychedelic renaissance right
now i think people who are
even remotely involved with that should
study
their history and there's an increased
maybe related increased interest in
intentional communities and communal
living
so i would love to hear why after a
while
you guys did not want to live community
in the way that you had been
what were the issues i'd say the biggest
issue
was that we were americans
born and raised on the milk of
individuality
and comfort
and neither of those things are
served that well when you're trying to
live communally
now i wouldn't trade like the seven
years i lived that way for
anything i learned so much about humans
and about the extent of our capacity
to be in each other's space but you know
if you look at other cultures
especially tribal cultures or even india
let's say
or china this obsession with
individuality and individual space
is not as laced into the dna
of the culture as it is here in america
or the west
it was very hard for me and for us and
i'm a pretty communal person i
i like being around people it was
difficult to
share decision making about everything
from how do we eat
to what constitutes good behavior among
children
you know we used to have extensively
long meetings about how much
cheese can each child eat
can we each have a dog can we have pets
oh
that's a good uh yeah it seems like a
small thing or
personal decision but it's not and these
conversations because we
also believed in something i highly
dissuade you from consensus
every decision had to be agreed upon to
all
150 people let's say in the room it
you know this would just go on forever
and ever
so there's community living and there's
community living we were taking it
to a real extreme a lot of people
in a small place everybody having kids
and
trying to create our own financial
systems and
so i would say for me
there were a few things that made me
unable to tolerate
that anymore one was when i had my kids
and i i really just didn't want to share
parenting that intimately with other
people
and the other thing was i just began to
have these
cravings for things like my own washing
machine
more cheese i want 20 grams of
additional cheddar goddammit
anyway it's it's a beautiful instinct
and i think it's um even a fantastic
phase to experiment with
and it's antidotal it's an
antidote to excessive individuality
individualism and you learn a lot
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
layered superfood founded by one of the
kings of big wave surfing laird hamilton
and volleyball champion gabby reese
layered superfood delivers high impact
fuel to help you get through your
busiest days i just had
a bunch of their products this morning
about an hour and a half
ago i love their turmeric superfood
creamer and the unsweetened
superfood creamer both can really
optimize your daily coffee or tea
rituals so i combined it with poo air
tea
a 10 bag will last you a long time i
basically
use the unsweetened superfood creamer
like powdered mct oil so if i'm doing
intermittent fasting or any number of
things i will use that
and i use it at least i would say four
or five times a week the creamers are
packed with real
plant-based ingredients like organic
extra virgin coconut oil coconut milk
and aquaman
they come in flavors like cacao and as i
mentioned turmeric
each serving is packed with a full range
of mcts medium chain triglycerides
to help keep you going from am to pm and
i have spent time with i've stayed at
the home of
laird and gabby and they are one of the
most powerful couples
i've ever met in my life they've been on
the podcast as well
so they introduced me to these products
and i've been hooked
for a limited time layered superfood is
offering you guys
20 off your order when you use code
tim20 at checkout
that's tim20
check out layeredsuperfood.com tim to
see my favorite products
and learn more once again use code tim20
to get 20
off your order go to
layeredsuperfood.com
tim
not to belabor the topic of curriculum
but i would love to
just hear you comment on in those
early years how you chose the teachers
and the topics was it a reflection
of your personal and i use yours
plural but in terms of leadership in the
founding team
was it a reflection of your personal
interest did you pull
or ask possible students what they would
like to have and therefore you were
guaranteed to have some attendance how
did
you think about picking and choosing
from the universe of possibilities
because
you know one of the challenges with
lots of options is the paradox of choice
right you you have
so many different possibilities within
arm's reach it can be very difficult
to filter and select how did you do that
it is difficult
to filter and select and a lot of what
we
offered and i was in the early years
that
the person who uh chose the most of the
curriculum we all
had a hand in it so a lot of it was just
what are we interested in
and this assumption that if we're
interested in it at least
some other people might be interested in
it
but also this idea that you know the
tagline of omega is awakening
the best in the human spirit
so i'm not an athlete but
i knew that for some people awakening
their best
was athletics that athletics was going
to be the door
to everything to excellence
to getting in the zone
to experiencing a world beyond your own
small
limited ego self i i knew that that
was a gateway for many people
so i'm a very curious person and
i'm also look for connectivity
everywhere
so like i would like start experimenting
for myself let's say in yoga
which i loved it was really my first
experience of awakening the body through
movement
and i thought oh my goodness i don't
know [ __ ] about this
there are people out there who like
are making the body as their path i
don't know about this i better find out
and so i would research and read
and even though it wasn't necessarily my
biggest interest
i wanted omega to be truly holistic
so and once you open those doors as you
say like
where do you stop because we've had some
pretty like
out there courses at omega out there
teachers and you can get so far out on
the fringe
that are actually offering quackery
and harmful things so
one of the the the first gates
was that this cannot harm anyone and
it can't be like so
out there that it's going to ruin our
reputation as
as a place that isn't it even a little
rigorous
in its selection process but somebody
might disagree with that because we've
had faith healers
and people who believe that there are
ufos
and you know one of your favorite
teachers terence mckenna who's it was a
consciousness ethnobotanist
who some people might say was crazy
mechanical elves mechanical elves
it's it's hard for uh most folks to make
sense of mechanical elves
inside joke right but i would sit in
especially in our early years i would
sit in on as many as the of the
workshops and conferences as i could
just so i could kind of ascertain
is this person whose book we read a good
teacher
is there ethics here is there a moral
morality here you know we had to draw
some lines
like if a person was exploring sexuality
but began to have like sort of orgies in
the classroom
no we're not doing that we're not going
there everyone must be clothed and no
one is having sex you know
we had to like draw some lines if we're
talking about
medicine you know like consciousness
medicine we're not taking it here
we are a business we have the health
department coming here we
are going to follow all the laws so
there were some ethical decisions and
there were some
just sort of let's keep it a little
tighter than everything
but boy we experimented far and wide in
the arts
in sports in all sorts of ecumenical
spiritual religious
traditions what do you mean by
ecumenical in this case
sometimes it means i think a collection
of or multiple influences from christian
churches but here i feel like maybe
you're using it
in a different capacity yeah i'm using
it as not just christian but all
churches
so multi-religious let's let's okay
let's not use that i might be using it
incorrectly
so multi-religion and multi-mysticism
and shamanism and indigenous cultures
and
you know and there's been over these 40
years there's been
trends it's been really interesting to
see what
trends come and go i mean on one level
there's nothing new under the sun
there are ways that different
generations and
different times people speak and learn
in different ways
yeah it's so true what was once old is
yet new again i mean there's so many
things that
at least in my lifetime and certainly
you know yours
move in cycles and it makes for a
fascinating study now
there are topics you can exclude or
things that might be harmful
if we're taking the sort of hippocratic
oath first do no harm
for the selection of courses and
teachers and then there's
assessing both the teachers and the
students
and i'm going to use that as a segue to
a word
that i believe you coined that i'd love
for you to
explain and that is innervism
could you please explain what innervism
is i have always been
an activist meaning i'm very interested
in what
might make change to the suffering of
humankind
whether it's political or social justice
or environmental or feminism
you know i have one foot firmly in the
activist
aspect of my nature but then there's the
seeker and the mystic
and because the word mysticism or
spiritual they they have a lot of
trappings that
you say the word spiritual to someone
and they think it's too
woo-woo or mysticism sounds like
whoa that's not me so i came up with the
word
innervism if activism is how
you relate to the injustices in the
world
innervism is how you
interact with all of the layers of who
you
are your psychology your wounding
your mystical bent your nature
your nurture all the different parts
that
you know you're a internal family system
lover i know that you love that
psychological school
there are parts inside of us and
how do you listen to them and determine
which ones you want to listen to
and how do you activate them and put
them in charge
of a better life so it's an exploration
of your
inner life and how to make it
like purevaliate always said put your
soul
in charge of your life how do you put
the best of your inner
self in charge of your life if i may i'm
just going to read and you can please
fact check me if any of this sounds
suspicious but a portion from an
interview that i found in the course of
doing research for this interview
that's related to aneurysm and it goes
as follows
i began to notice that a lot of the
people working for justice and peace
causes were really angry people people
who had never taken care of themselves
and were projecting their own stuff all
over their issues
i thought how are we ever going to
spread peace and justice for not working
on it in
ourselves i want to walk this path in
every part of my life and that involves
some kind of inner work
that's why i call it innervism i want to
work on my own peace of mind so i can be
a real peacemaker
if we can match up what we want out
there with what's going on in ourselves
we will be
much better activists so
if that sounds like something that you
might have said i mean
even if it doesn't i agree with it
and i agree with it too all right
perfect and you know
it just it makes me uh think of a few
things number one
jack cornfield who's been on this
podcast and i consider a friend
and likes to say something along the
lines of remember your buddha nature
and also your social security number i
think there's a sometimes a tendency to
put the let's just call it spiritual
although i want to come back to that
word and
help us to define it for at least share
how you define it the spiritual or the
esoteric
in place of some of the practical and
i won't mention names but i was at a
different retreat center ones
and i'm sitting in the cafe and i was
drinking my
yerba mate tea because it's a it's a
very uh
acceptable way to get hyper stimulated
and
i was overhearing this conversation
where this this woman was complaining
and complaining to someone else about
all sorts of things the landlord
this that the other thing and then
her friend asked uh how she's doing
if she's thinking about moving and she
said well i'm really having trouble
paying my rent but i've just been really
busy getting non-dual and
and i thought huh that strikes me as a
problem
but in any case there isn't really a
question there i suppose it's it's
just an in agreement with
this type of framing i think it's it's
really important
in fact about oh i don't know maybe 15
years ago
35 years 30 years in i don't know
to our work we really began to be
tired of ourselves teaching this
technology of
inner awakening to the same people over
and over it's like
how many times you have to wake up in
the morning you know you're awake
do something so we started
we called it internally the movement
from me to we
and we started inviting for free several
weeks out of every
season non-profit groups working at the
front lines of of all sorts of
environmental social justice work
to come for free with their entire team
to omega and to give them whatever they
felt they needed in terms of self-care
and lining up what was going on inside
and within their team
and their work in the world and we have
done this now with hundreds and hundreds
of non-profits
taking what we know and giving it to the
people who can really use it
because as you said often you'll look at
a group of people working for social
change
and they're just so angry and they're
not communicating well amongst
themselves and there
there's a lot of ego at the forefront
and
some of these spiritual technologies can
not just help people be happier
but can serve the work we all
want to do in the world i certainly
agree with that statement
and i think this is a good place to take
a look at this word
spiritual and i'd love to hear you
expand on your
definition of that term i think that as
you said a lot of people have an
allergic reaction to that term
not necessarily because they dislike the
definition
or the connotation it's that in so many
conversations it can be very
slippery and end up being a catch-all
that doesn't really have a clear
definition on the other hand for
instance you mentioned mysticism
i'm fond of that word because
to me at least it implies a direct
experience of the divine
and if you don't like that word divine
you could replace it with sacred you
could place it with
nature but it's a direct subjective
experience that
isn't really subject to debate on some
level so i quite like the
purity of experience that that
connotates but spiritual
how would you define that for yourself
or suggest people think about it
well i also prefer the word mysticism
and the root of it being
mystery we dwell in mystery
no one has figured this out yet folks if
they had bought it
where do you go when you die can you
communicate with the ancestors who
passed over
how do we live a moral life you know
these are all mysteries
that people have been exploring forever
so i love the word mysticism meaning a
way of approaching
and relaxing into the mystery
spirituality you know you got to go back
to the word spirit
which is the indwelling
nature of all things i was just
every morning i pick a quote from a huge
basket of quotes i have and i try to
live by it
and this morning i picked a line from
the poet gerard manly hopkins
and he wrote there lives the dearest
freshness deep down things
the dearest freshness to me that
that might be spirituality like
what is so fresh and dear
and essential about anything
that tree that bird you told me before
we
started taping that you were watching
that person in front of you
that fear of yours that wound of yours
what is the dearest freshness deep
down inside now
somebody might say there is no dearest
freshness deep down inside it all
just it's you know the sort of
nihilistic
approach so i i can't really define
spirituality for
people who don't have some sort of
connection
to or
faith that there is an essential
consciousness that is fresh and dear
but that to me is what spiritual
seeking is all about see she mentioned
earlier these non-profit groups and so
on
frontline workers coming into a mega
institute
and that initiative being started
to help those those people take these
tools and put them into action right and
that these
practices are not necessarily solely for
or they are not necessarily
for practice in the meditation hall
right remember i can't remember who it
was might have been tara brock or
jack cornfield telling me story of
these various people in meditation
retreats who would get pissed off
super pissed off about something and
they would say i need to go to the
meditation hall right now and they would
run
back to deal with their anger in the
meditation hall and just how
just such as a hilarious and unfortunate
image that that conjures because so
divorced
from implementing these things in sort
of ordinary
reality and building practices that can
withstand reality so so i'd love to talk
about
your sister's bone marrow transplant
and how some of
this awareness has been translated and
specifically i have a note in front of
me and i don't
i don't have any more context than this
but the quote
do no harm and take no [ __ ] meditation
what is this meditation and how did it
come about
well i found a needle point with that
slogan do no harm but take no
[ __ ] in my sister's study
office after she had died she's my
little sister
and i come from a family of four
daughters
and maggie my youngest sister was the
most you know like if there was a
favorite adorable one who everyone loved
it was
maggie and she was a nurse practitioner
and an artist and a very tough customer
she thought just about everything i did
in my life she called it
[Music]
voodoo she was a western medicine
you know she she lived in vermont and
her
patients were all the rural poor
and she just had very little tolerance
for the woo-woo stuff
we had a loving yet we're so different
relationship and there were times like
in all siblings lives where we
weren't the kindest to each other and
when she
was diagnosed with a very serious
lymphoma and the only thing that would
save her life
was a bone marrow transplant and for any
of you listening
who know about the science of
blood cancers the really serious ones
are you will die within weeks if you
don't treat it and
bone marrow transplants almost kill you
in order to save you and so
siblings are the ones who are most
likely to have a good
match dna match of the of the stem cells
that is found
in the bones in the marrow
and so each of our sisters were tested
and i was the one
who tested as her perfect match we
lined up 10 for 10 which is considered a
perfect
match and this was exciting but also
mystifying to all of us since
maggie and i were so different and when
i studied
up on the science of bone marrow
transplant
what can happen once the donor's bone
marrow gets
into the patient is that the patient can
reject it or the
donors cells can attack the patient
they call it rejection or attack attack
or rejection
and that's the actual word
medical term and when i heard that i
thought to myself well that's what my
sister and i have done our whole life
we've we've attacked each other we've
rejected each other
like and since i believe in the mind
body
connection you know your own if you're
nervous and stressed you can get a cold
your cells can you know your immune
cells
can be diminished by your stress i
thought well if every cell in her body
after the transplant is mine because
that's what happens in a bone marrow
transplant
they kill all of her blood cells and
every
bit that is reproduced comes from my
stem cells
it's a little more complicated than that
but that's the basic science of it
and i thought well like if my they're
all my cells
i certainly want to work on our ancient
rejection and attack because maybe we
could teach ourselves how to get along
and so i suggested to my sister
should we do some therapy together which
for her was like
so anathema to what she's all about but
you know when your life is
when you're about to die you'll do
anything you'll jump out of a
plane you know this was her jumping out
of a plane going
into therapy with me and we did that
and we worked on our relationship very
quickly because we didn't have much time
it was amazing we called it our soul
marrow transplant
not a stem cell transplant but a soul
marrow transplant and
we we did this clearing with each other
where we looked at the assumptions we
had made about each other
over our many years of being sisters and
we cleared them with each other did you
mean that no
what did you mean it was amazing we fell
so deeply in love
and she lived for a year after
the transplant she called it the best
year of her life
because she was able to kind of start
doing that same work with other people
like letting go of assumptions and
coming into
cleaner fuller relationships
after she died and i was going through
her office i came across
that needle point framed needlepoint
do no harm and take no [ __ ] and do no
harm is the hippocratic oath
which she was a medical practitioner
but then she was also someone who was
very aware
that nurses often take a whole lot of
[ __ ]
from the medical professionals above
them
and so she and her fellow nurses loved
that slogan
do no harm but like know who you are and
have a strong backbone and have some
boundaries
and it reminded me of a
of a very common buddhist practice you
see the iconography
of the buddha or kuan yin with
one hand the right hand up in a stop
mudra gesture like you're putting your
hand out like stop
and then the left hand is a cup it's the
gesture the mudra of compassion it's
you're holding all the suffering of the
world in your hand
and transmuting it into care
and then there's the other hand which is
saying stop
and it felt to me like it was a good way
to describe what that meditation that
buddhist meditation is it's like
you can be so open to the suffering
of the world and of your own heart keep
your heart
wide wide open that is the path
of the sacred seeker but
if you don't have a strong backbone and
that's why you see in meditation the
posture of a strong back
if you don't have that strong backbone
and that ability to say
no i have boundaries i know who i
am i am valid i belong here
if you don't work with those two things
together
you either become too hard you know that
stop can just make you so rigid and hard
and kind of like an [ __ ]
or if you're too open and too sensitive
and too soft you just get run over
because
that's what happens so that is
to me like a noble meditation
do no harm and take no [ __ ] first of all
i just want to
express sincere condolences for your
sister i can't imagine
losing my younger brother and i can only
imagine how hard that must have been
and secondly i'd like to revisit
that clearing that you described so i've
read you
speak about add
but not as we might commonly think of
add authenticity deficit disorder
and i would love to hear
you explain what that is and then
also give any advice to those who might
want to have clearing conversations
with people close to them and work on
add authenticity deficit disorder
well authenticity is one of those buzz
words like spirituality that
has you know some people don't like that
word
or it's been overused or there's this
idea that
all you have to do is be yourself and
then everything will just work out
forgetting that there are other people
out there who may
react to your authentic self
in not the most loving way
so i just want to put a caveat on
the idea that all you have to do is work
on
uncovering your authentic self but
add all of us have
this ever since childhood these scripts
that we have to fit in
that there's a way to be and that
there's something about the way you are
that isn't right i mean if you ask
almost anyone
i tend especially recently having
written this book about women
to focus more on you know the imposter
syndrome and add
in women but i know men have it too a
sense that there's something
fundamentally wrong with me and i gotta
hide it
and i have to correct it by being like
all those other people and you know we
get these scripts from
our parents our school if we're a person
of color
there's the white supremacy way to be if
we're a woman
in business we need to be more like the
warrior man
men have to be a certain
way within relationship there's all
these like
confusing scripts that keep us from
finding well who am i what is my gift
and and how can i be that in the world
and the way that related to the
conversation
i had with my sister these sessions we
only did three of these sessions with
this
wonderful therapist who walked us
back and back and back into our
childhood
and what we uncovered
was that each of us thought the other
one
didn't really value like or see us
we felt judged and without
taking the time ever because none of us
are taught this to say
is this what you think about me is this
what you need me to be to be loved by
you
instead of checking it out we did all
sorts of weird things attacking each
other rejecting each other
feeling hurt lashing out never
having those essential conversations of
how do you see me what do you need from
me
what is going on in our relationship
that's keeping us from connecting
how do we meet each other in each of our
core authenticities in a way that
creates love and a creative relationship
so we needed that help and
there's i'm sure you know this and
listeners you all know this too
there's some sort of bizarre magic that
happens
when we put down what roomie the great
sufi poet calls the open
secret this secret that we're all
carrying around that we don't
we don't live up to what other people
who other people are that we're somehow
flawed
and all kinds of weird coping mechanisms
come from that
when we put that down when we just show
up with the other person
am i enough oh yeah you're enough
you're enough stop trying to be
something else
you're okay and you you find that
enoughness
in each other it's like a freaking
miracle
and it's not that hard but it's scary
you know i write about this in my
new book i was asked after 9 11 a lot of
people were asked
social workers therapists mindfulness
teachers
to go and do a lot of the first
responders
had to take these ptsd courses and they
didn't have enough teachers
and so i was leading mindfulness
meditation
classes for first responders in new york
city
um about six months after 9 11.
i did it for maybe i don't know three
months
it's a short course in teaching basic
mindfulness skills
and everything was going fine with these
guys who i absolutely adored
until i tried to bring
the idea of mindfulness into being
mindful
in our relationships with others and
really getting down
into what's going on for you in your
soft
heart that was no they were not going
to go there it was terrifying it was
easier for them
to go into a burning building on 911
than to get soft with their wife or
their
colleague their friend and to say what
they needed
to apologize to express fears
and wounds so it's a courageous
act to bring your authentic self into a
relationship
and it takes some training and some help
so
i would say let's say you have someone
in your life you'd like to
do some of this exploration with
forgiveness
acceptance explanation
seeing hearing i would say
get some help do it with a witness a
coach
or a therapist because it can go south
really quickly
and and so commit to it
and don't do it with someone who doesn't
want to do it you cannot drag
someone onto the dance floor there has
to be some
shared interest in this idea you know
i'd like to
throw out a question and idea
just because i've seen it play out in my
own life
and it may seem counter to what you just
said but i think that
it's very case by case and that is in
preparing for this and
reading about add in this case
authenticity deficit disorder
there were a few examples in interviews
of questions that represent these open
secrets
that you then ask your sister such as
and
please let me know if this if any of
this is incorrect but you know when i
got divorced
why did you reject me in the time i
needed you so much or
for a while you barely let me in your
home what was that about
these are big questions and open
secrets like you said and i have
in my experience sometimes
found that not
value necessarily in dragging someone to
the dance floor
but just in the asking of the question
there can be an incredible unburdening
and that it wasn't an
answer solely an answer
that was required to help that
unburdening but just the asking of the
question
if that makes any sense the releasing of
that open secret
and i would be curious to know if if
that resonates at all
or if you have found that to be true at
all in your experience
i think it's so critical and such a
beautiful revelation one thing i've
i've really feel i've learned better
since that work with my sister and just
getting older
there does not have to always be
resolution
there often just has to be the questions
it's like you don't have to pull out
every single stick from the cleared out
river
you can just pull out a few so that
there's a little more movement
and let trust that that movement
will do its thing i've been such a
fierce seeker and experimenter
with so many different psychological and
mystical
and medicine traditions like going
for it and i'm gonna clear out every
stick in the river and
i've really loosened up on that
it's like do a little bit give it
a really good try work on
your ego's need though to control
everything and just just see what
happens little by little and then throw
it up to the face
i certainly got a big
download about what you just said in
that work with my sister
such a beautiful story and certainly
such a sad story
uh do you have any recommendations for
people related to
grieving uh this is something i i have i
have a number of close friends who've
lost their parents and
and struggled incredibly to process
those experiences
not to say there is any easy way nor
should there be an easy way
but we seem to really lack any structure
or certainly i i think there's a
dearth of meaningful rituals related to
mourning
in secular in the secular united states
and i'm sure elsewhere
do you have any suggestions recommended
resources anything for those
who are grieving i love the words
grief and mourning i think
grief is
just a sign of how well you loved
grief is like a badge
of honor you loved you are a lover
and of course you're gonna grieve
depending on
how much you give of your heart when the
object of your love is
gone it's gonna hurt and
part of consumer
culture is that we look for closure
which is one of my least favorite words
i'm just into keeping it open
keeping the heart wide open
because if you shut down to pain you
shut down to joy
we all kind of know this intellectually
you know that the heart is a big
muscle and you keep it wide open you're
going to feel everything
and it's it's very understandable that
we'd close down the heart
you get wounded as a child you shut down
but then you shut down
to everything so one thing is to
buck the system that says
your mother died you should go back to
work in three days
like in the old country you would wear
black
for a year and you'd see the
woman in black walking in the town
square and you'd say
oh oh give her space give her room
she's mourning or you sit shiva in the
old jewish traditions
for a year or just cultures indigenous
cultures where
uh the underworld the underworld of
darkness and loss and feeling
these are like sacred places to go into
and we've lost that because it's it's
not productive
to grieve so instead you swallow it
and you end up really not being
productive at all because you're
drinking too much and eating too much
and working too much
just to cover the wound so it's both to
me a structural social thing that we
don't give
time for grief and loss and mourning
but it's also a individual's
courage to feel it all
all the way through and to ask it to
have its way with you
and teach me and to wear it as a badge
of love
to wear your grief proudly and not to
think you have to have
closure so many excellent points
and now i'll just add
that uh one book that really helped one
of my friends after the loss of his
father
was on grief and grieving finding the
meaning of grief through the five stages
of loss
by elizabeth kubler-ross and david
kessler and he
said that he wished he had read it
before the passing of his dad that it
would have
actually served as incredible
preparation it would have been very
helpful preemptively
and so he he recommended it to me and
many others
just based on that experience of his i
yeah i
i i recommend lots of books on grief and
death you know that there's a
wonderful sufi saying or maybe it's a
buddhist saying i don't remember
die before death and then do whatever
you want it's all
good so really
owning that we all die we all lose and
making friends with that you know
pema children a buddhist teacher i've
studied with a lot
she calls mindfulness unconditional
friendliness that's great
so having unconditional friendliness to
loss
and grief and change it's hard it's a
hard practice but
any of those books to read about grief
and loss before they happen it's
preparation
so that you can welcome the inevitable
are there any books that come to mind
offhand that you would or might
recommend
there's one by a catholic
mystic he's no longer alive on ree
nuyen n-o-w-e-n
i think could be n-o-u-w-e-n
and i think it's called on grief
it's a small book and it's a beautiful
book
and that that book by kessler and
elizabeth cooper ross
are is also a wonderful book
it is henry n-o-u-w-e-n
and i'm sure that if we do a quick
search
for grief the book may be
the blessing hidden in grief that's at
least one essay that he has
written but certainly people can say oh
it's something
like letters of consolation something
like that there is
there is also a letter of consolation
yeah that's the book
yeah and uh so we'll link to all of
these in the show notes as well for
everyone at tim dot blog slash podcast
one more note and then i want to ask
about the new book and explore that a
bit
i think we may have to do if you're open
to it in round two i am so enjoying this
conversation
and taking furious notes just for myself
which
is is always exciting for me that the
first is
just to touch again on your wonderful
metaphor of clearing a few sticks from
the river you don't have to clear
every last bit of detritus to make a lot
of progress and
it makes me think of a quote that i've
kept in mind
and revisited often from of all things a
very famous track coach
named hank kreijenhoff i'm not
pronouncing that correctly but what else
is new
and his quote was
and his athletes performed spectacularly
one merlin joyce who is considered queen
of the track merlin joyce adi
had 23 combined medals at the olympic
games and world championships that's
just one athlete
and his quote was do as little as needed
not as much as possible
and i think this is really helpful
to keep in mind when you are
quote unquote doing the work because
there there are points of diminishing
returns and there are also costs
when you are sort of constantly whipping
your back
i love that that's that's a fantastic
quote
it's so true it is not something that i
learned
until somewhat recently and i
i think it's really important and there
are diminishing returns and there
are problems that you create by
excessive anything yeah there's uh
white knuckling is not a free lunch
not to say you shouldn't do things that
are uncomfortable but if you become
obsessed on
constantly doing things that are
uncomfortable guess what your life is
going to be
consistently very uncomfortable which is
isn't always the ideal uh and it makes
it actually sometimes quite difficult to
be
unconditionally friendly in the
mindfulness sense
that you mentioned which i also
love so much your new book and
let's start with my weakness yet again
can you please pronounce
i've heard both i have friends who
pronounce these differently so how do
you pronounce
is it cassandra speaks or cassandra
speaks well i don't really know either
i chose cassandra because cassandra
sounded
affected and i'm very effective to begin
with so
i need to i need to stem the tide here a
bit all right
cassandra speaks when women are the
storytellers
the human story changes what is the
genesis
of this book writing takes a lot of
effort
it takes a lot of time it's a huge
commitment
why this book about 20 years ago i
started
i curated one conference at omega i've
curated many conferences on so many
different subjects
and i often i'll do a conference based
on what seems to be making people
uncomfortable that's funny
given our little bit of last
conversation but like what makes people
kind of
whoa wake up and say why does that make
me uncomfortable
yeah the proper dose of discomfort and
so this was
putting the words women and power
together like what if i create a
conference called women and power
and we just explore that so i invited
just like four or five different
speakers one was
anita hill and the clarence thomas
hearings had really we're still fresh in
the american mind
where anita hill had been
brought into the hearings and she
accused
clarence thomas who was up for the
becoming a supreme court
judge the first black supreme court
judge and she accused him of
sexual impropriety and she
was treated very poorly and he of course
was appointed
the judge and she really put the word
sexual harassment on the map
and i also invited a friend of mine eve
ensler who wrote the vagina monologues
and a couple of other people to explore
what happens when women become powerful
how does the world react
what happened to you what's going on
when we put these words together
and it was so explosively
popular hundreds of people came i was
surprised i thought maybe like
50 people would come so i repeated it
the next year
and the next year like by the third year
there were 2 000
women and a smattering of very brave men
in the audience
in a ballroom in new york city in a
hotel and every year since then
i have had this conference with
everything from all the women nobel
peace prize winners
to activists and artists and the first
woman astronaut and just
any woman who's a maverick and breaking
the mold
and asking herself what do i do with my
power
and can i do power differently
and does that have anything to do with
me being a woman
these were the questions we were asking
and i would give a
keynote every year to start it off and i
thought
actually when my daughter-in-law said
why don't you just take all those
speeches and turn them into a book
i knew better that it wasn't going to be
that easy because books are never
easy they're in fact they're horribly
hard
and i said yeah yeah maybe i'll do that
and i started work on it and i sold it
to my publisher and i got the contract
and then so much happened in the culture
around women
in the three or four years i was writing
the metoo movement
trump things like that intersectionality
black lives matter it was a really
difficult writing project
to write about the old myths the old
origin stories from the bible and the
greeks and all the western traditions
that have painted women in one way
the old power books i went back and read
you know machiavelli
and sons and and different
business texts that describe what
leadership and heroism look
like and i i just
spent these years exploring the research
in how women lead is it different how
women do the inner vision work so we
don't just you know nietzsche says
be careful when fighting monsters you
don't become one
that there was so much going on with
women getting
into the corporate world or into
leadership and then like nothing was
changing who cares
so that was the exploration and that's
was the genesis of the book why
cassandra
where does that name come from cassandra
was a mortal
princess in troy and troy and greece
were always having wars
and she was so beautiful she was the
youngest and most beautiful daughter of
king priam
queen hekiba in troy this is all greek
myth these are not real people
these are the myths just like adam and
eve they weren't real people
so these are stories that inform us
through the ages cassandra was so
alluring that even the gods wanted to
have her
an apollo son of zeus
wooed her by offering her a gift she
couldn't refuse she didn't understand
that
the gift came with the payment of being
his concubine but she wanted this gift
which was prophecy she would see into
the future
she would know what was going to happen
and then she would tell her people
in troy and so she could inform history
so he gave her the gift and then she
would not sleep with him so he cursed
her
he didn't just take the gift away he
said cassandra
you will know the future and you will
tell the future
but no one will believe you and so
as i was reading and studying that story
and other greek stories
i was watching the televised trial
of those hundreds of girls who had been
molested by dr larry nasser
you know he was the doctor for the
olympic committee and
michigan gymnastics gymnastics yeah
and over 30 years he had been claiming
to do
medical treatment on hundreds and
hundreds of girls
and young women but really he had been
sexually molesting them and they would
tell their mothers and fathers they
would tell their coaches
they would tell their university the
olympic committee
and no one would believe them year after
year
they took the word of this one man over
these girls
and finally some of the girls started
speaking out and speaking out
and there's this the judge who was
assigned the case in michigan
judge rosemary aquilina
just someone everyone should know about
she defied normal courtroom procedure
and she allowed any girl who wanted to
speak for as long as she wanted to speak
to tell her story the trial went on for
days
and dr nasser had to sit there and
listen to every single girl
tell her story and before each girl
spoke she would say
i hear you i see you your words
matter leave them here with me
and then go out and live your life and
they were believed
and i would watch these little girls
faces and by now some were women
because some of these girls were
molested at like nine years old
and their whole countenance would change
with the experience of telling their
truth being validated
so i decided of all the stories that i
unpack in the book whether it's
eve or pandora or literary women
i decided to call it cassandra speaks
because
it really speaks to me of
women know something of great value
just like men do but our stories and our
instincts
and our values and sort of our
because of both nature and nurture what
we
care about has been determined
as second-class behavior you know like
the caretaking roles they're not very
important
compared to a ceo or a fireman
the things that we hold dear and know
how to do
have been invalidated so that we don't
even trust ourselves
we don't trust what matters to us
matters the most in the world and that's
why
i named it cassandra so that we would
all start
telling our truths and demanding to be
heard and validated sounds like a lot
more work
than just stringing together a bunch of
speeches and
very worthwhile as a project
i would love to come back briefly to the
the nietzsche quote that you mentioned
you know in in i can't remember the
exact
quote but in fighting monsters we must
be careful that we do not become
monsters ourselves
in your reading it also sort of ties
into
and this is going to form into a
question gloria steinem has a quote
which is when we do acquire power we
meaning women we might turn out to have
an equal impulse towards aggression
do you have any thoughts on whether or
not that
is inevitable if we have an equal
impulse towards aggression
or do you have recommendations for
trying to mitigate that possibility
for women as more and more women gain
power to
help prevent abuses of power well this
really did become as i was writing
the question i was grappling with
especially as you look at many women who
gain power you look at some of
the women who are in congress now and
you think
really you want that story that's the
story you want how's that different
so where i have landed is
it's not so much that women
have less aggression actually i think we
do because
i'll go into that right now you know
we are both uh nurtured and natured
beings and if all you want to do
is look into the research of hormones
and the effect of estrogen and
testosterone and progesterone
and we most women do have more
estrogen and if you talk to people who
have gone through transition
trans people you know men who
get flooded with estrogen and how it
totally changes their experience
and vice versa women who are trans men
you know there's a great book out
recently of a woman who transitioned
into
being a man and suddenly wanted to
become a lightweight boxer because there
was so
much aggression and wanted to know how
to channel it
so there are distinctions between women
and men
and there's it's there's great variety
so it's very hard when writing about
all women and all men but in general
there's less aggression
in women you know there was this study
done in the 30s and 40s walter cannon
he was the one who came up with the word
fight or flight
so they did studies on human beings
brought them into the lab what happens
under simulated stress situations
measured the hormones measure different
chemicals in the blood
oh under stress all human beings fight
or flee well in 2007
shelly taylor a scientist at ucla
realized only men
were used in the laboratory none of
those studies were done on women
and that's the way most studies medical
studies psychological studies were done
in the
1960s 70s 80s all the way up until the
early 21st century so she brought women
into the lab and she did a lot of
research into
studies done on female animals and she
came up with the term
in a wonderful book that people i think
should read
called attending instinct
shelly taylor she came up with the
phrase
tend and befriend under stress
in these laboratory experiments
women's instincts were more to tend to
the most vulnerable
in whatever the tribe the clan the
family the
organization the business or befriend
you know women you come home from a hard
day at work
you're feeling really pissed off and
angry you call
three or four of your friends and you
talk it out
and you you feel these circles of
befriending
helping you sort things out and finding
new ways to deal
that's the befriending circles so under
stress women
often will tend or befriend so the human
instinct is not only to fight or flee
yes
everybody has the fight or flea but
everybody
also has the tend and befriend and it's
not a question of women good men bad
it's this imbalance of what we have
called
heroic and leadership which is all
the fight or flight without much of the
tend and befriend
i mean imagine just just like think of
um
some of the statues you see everywhere i
once made a study of this i walked
through central
park and i made a note of every single
statue in the park
and i think there's like something like
59 statues and like
50 of them were soldiers
were young men holding each other with
blood and
general sherman on a golden horse and
it just everywhere it was it was
soldiers
and generals and i thought now
now what if there was a statue of a
woman giving birth
with lots of blood and pain and her
helpers all around her
that would just seem so like weird
wouldn't it
like oh don't don't show that but
it's what you pay attention to as a
culture
and name heroic that everyone then wants
to be like
which has put tendon befriend type
people
at a disadvantage and also once you do
get into powerful
positions that's how you feel you need
to be and it goes against your authentic
core so i'm less interested in women
getting into power
and more interested in validating
and valuing and calling heroic the tend
and befriend instinct i think that's an
outstanding objective what impact
would you hope this book to have i mean
looking back
six months 12 months several years after
publication
is it a culture shaping effect
is there a particular hope that you have
of any type
i mean certainly you just named in uh
high level terms one such hope but is
does anything else come to mind for you
i think a lot about like i have three
sons
and they all have children now
and they are the most heroic
fathers they are in there with their
kids
on attend and befriend level just as
much
sometimes more than their wives
their wives have jobs they work hard
they make money
so do my sons but there is a
true expectation that
parenting is shared that would be one of
my great hopes from the book that
you know how we always say a girl can be
anything a boy can be
but we rarely say a boy can be
anything a girl can be i would like
that statement to
have a lot of clout that like
a boy would feel enormous pride
to have his tend and befriend
nature developed that
a man would be proud to cry and
share and talk and all the things that
are considered
you know oh women you know you're so you
talk too much
you're too emotional like that the
qualities
of emotional intelligence would be
really cool and hip and dudes would want
them
just to build on that this may be in the
chapter called in praise of fathers
there's a line i actually believe that
full-hearted fatherhood might save the
world
why is it needed and that might seem
like a silly question but i'm i'm
wondering
and perhaps a better way to ask the
question is what does full-hearted
fatherhood mean compared to what we more
commonly find
well one it's not a sense that you're
babysitting
that you're giving your partner this is
you know assuming it's a heterosexual
couple
that you're not giving your wife
some time off it's an assumption that
if women can
penetrate the old world of
male work world
and make money and work and be outside
the house
that men can make
equal interior changes that allows them
to
actually want and need to father
as much as women want and need to mother
and more than that um
i mothered pretty fiercely and i lost a
lot of
traction in the work world because of it
but i always knew someone had to take
care of the kids
and that was falling on me
i would like to live in a culture where
not only
is it expected of mothers it's also
expected of fathers but it's
also expected of the society
so that we have child care and that we
have
parental leave and that because
it all starts with the kids in the home
that's where it all starts you know
gloria steinem you quoted her she said
oh
i'm forgetting it fully but if we want
to have
justice outside the home we have to have
it in the home
if we want to have freedom outside the
home we have to have it inside the home
so it starts with enlightened families
and relationships so
that's full-hearted fathering
to me is knowing that it's that it's a
masculine valid that
there's a lot of muscle given to it you
know
like i love that men
love excellence and strength
and uh muscle and
you know all the i don't know you could
probably come up with better adjectives
but i want
care and love to have equal amounts
of muscle elizabeth just a few more
questions and then certainly we can save
save room i have many pages of
additional questions left over which is
good news
so perhaps we can do a another
conversation at some point but
let me just ask a few more and the first
is absolutely metaphorical but if you
had a huge billboard
conversely if you just want to send
something to every person's smartphone
if you want to think about it that way
upon which you could put
a phrase a quote an image
a question anything like that what might
you
put on that billboard oh wow that's
asking a lot i'm like a
quote [ __ ] i have so many quotes
um i think it would probably
be not either or
but both and more hmm
that's fantastic that is excellent and
and the last question is do you have any
closing comments questions you'd like to
pose
to my audience requests you would like
to make of them anything at all
you'd like to add before we bring this
conversation
to a close just to be gentle on yourself
that i think my favorite thing about
what we talked about today tim
was this idea of the stick in the river
that
you know to to work hard to pursue
excellence but to be
forgiving and gentle you know we're all
bozos on the bus
we're all tripping over ourselves and
it's okay
it's okay it's all right
uh elizabeth elizabeth lesser uh what a
what a
superstar you can be found at
elizabethlesser.org
all over social including facebook a liz
lesser instagram
liz lesser twitter at elizabeth lesser
your newest book
is cassandra speaks subtitle when women
are the storytellers
the human story changes of course
everyone listening you can find show
notes links to everything we discussed
at tim.log forward slash podcast
and elizabeth what a treat thank you so
much for taking the time today
thank you for having me and to
everyone listening thanks for tuning in
and until next time be gentle on
yourself
we're all bozos on the bus together
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's four
hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by all form
if you've been listening to this podcast
for a while you've probably heard me
talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017 i have two of them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost
of traditional stores so i'm sitting in
my living room right now and it's
entirely all formed furniture i've got
two chairs i've got an ottoman
and i have an l sectional couch and i'll
come back to that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stained and scratch resistant the
soap
color the color of the legs the soap
size the shape to make sure it's perfect
for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
8c
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural light finish which is
their lightest color
and i dig it and i've been using these
things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping
and you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it that's more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked
it worked much better than i could have
imagined and i'm very very
happy so to find your perfect sofa check
out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout this episode is brought to
you by
tonal that's t-o-n-a-l tonal is the
world's most intelligent home gym and
personal trainer that's the tagline from
their website folks
so it gives you the one sentence summary
by eliminating traditional metal weights
total can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen
tv it mounts right on your wall with no
floor space required
i've had one for a few months now after
a number of close friends
recommended tonal to me and it allows me
to do things that i would normally need
a huge gym for
like cable chop and lift or rotational
exercises and it allows me to do
other things that are nearly impossible
otherwise
like eccentric loading which i'll talk
about again later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights
and ai learning together with the best
experts in resistance training so you
can get stronger faster one of my
friends who used to be a competitive
skier
very high level competitive skier has
doubled his strength in many exercises
over a period of months
so what are these adaptive digital
weights tonal's patented
digital weight system makes thousands of
calculations a second to deliver you a
smooth weightlifting experience using
their advanced electronic
motor technology and a lot of the
buttons are built right into the handles
themselves
into the grips so you don't need to move
around and
it is extremely easy to use tonal lets
you adjust the weight in one pound
increments and you can do it on the fly
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down
with just the touch of a button tonal
also has built-in dynamic weight modes
like chains eccentric and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains and bands
the eccentrics which i mentioned means
that you can
set a mode that allows you to say just
as an example bicep curl
15 pounds up and then lower
automatically
20 25 pounds down and it is incredible
how much you can get done in just a
handful of minutes
when you use this type of technology so
check it out
tritonal t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest
home gym for 30 days in your home if you
don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.comtonal.com and for a
limited time get 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code
tim21 like i'm ready for
my first drink at checkout that's
www.tonaltonal.com
promo code tim 21 tim21
tonal be your strongest